when jack and i wrote chicken soup 144
publishers turned us down which is
unbelievable
what are you guys doing don't you get it
nobody wants i said no the audience
wants it
now is a perfect time for us to do the
self-interrogation
self-inquiry to say hey what is it i can
do it how is it i can do it how far can
i go
you've got to know how to ask
we've got a legend in the house mark
victor hansen
uh well known obviously for his chicken
soup for the soul series but also has a
new
book out called ask and he calls it the
bridge from your dreams to your destiny
there it is i love it i love the
the colors too the purple and the yellow
it just pops so hard
and it's about it's about asking it's
about asking people for help it's about
not trying to do everything yourself
and uh tell me why
this book right now
what happens is my wife and i have
traveled as you know to 80 countries and
talk to seven million people
and we meet great people wonderful
people educated people foreign people
but
basically they lack they don't go to
their full destiny because they lack the
ability to ask whether it was
thwarted in childhood or during the
educational system or in business saying
who do you think you are asking me or in
military or whatever it is
so we decided to do is write everything
we knew about asking
and then we um checked it all out at
harvard and stanford and cambridge and
then
we interviewed the 26 best askers we
know
and all of them come back to the same
thing saying you've got to know how to
ask
and it seems so simple it seems so easy
but it's profound
and like yesterday we got 121 letters
from people saying they've read it it
came out april 28th and they've had
transformational experiences so
forgive me for saying it but i think i
got lightning in a bottle for a second
time in my life
and i think you know our chicken soup
sold a half billion i think i'll sell a
half billion more in this series how's
that well i love it i love it
now i think a lot of people who are
givers who are caring who are
you know heart centric or trying to
bring value feel like
asking is whether it's selfish whether
it's
whether it's icky or whether it's just
they feel super uncomfortable doing it
because they feel that it's not right so
so but then they never get their goals
and they never get the help that they
need so what would you tell
the giver who is struggling to ask for
help
i do first of all i love the question
and and i did write a little book called
the miracle of giving or the miracle of
tithing
and i say you gotta for it you know you
you gotta uh first of all
um the fourties to it thinking time
talent and treasures and
and nobody no philanthropy and i the
reason i've sold more books than anybody
alive i think
is because we tithe in every one of our
books uh starting from the beginning and
and so that opens up the windows of
heaven as you know that old cliche in
malachi
the the point is is that all of us got
to learn how to give and and what's
happened with ask we're saying
you got three forms of giving ask
yourself ask others ask god
and what's happening is that people are
finding out hey wait a second i can
really find illumination insight
um and and find out who i really am at
the core of my being
and especially during this sequestration
period
uh what's happened is it you know my our
corporate symbol is a butterfly i think
you know that and i just looked at my
stuff
just like i looked at all your stuff and
what happens is you can't look at a
caterpillar and predict butterfly and
we're all in this
wonderful cocoon it's not so wonderful a
lot of levels a lockdown of 8 billion of
us
but out of that we're going to have some
greatest the greatest breakthroughs i
predict in human history how's that
i love it now people are already asking
in the live chat where where is the best
place to get the book
well thank you everybody i'd ask you to
go to amazon and get it or
um and then once you got it get a buddy
which is what your real question is
that you can test asking like you know
you
i have you ever been in any of my
seminars live in the old days
no okay because tony robbins i ran the
biggest seminar but
we're back we're coming back the
seminars are starting to open up we're
getting hired in nevada and florida
again
it's sort of a mind blower to me but the
point is we say buddy up get two people
together and go through every question
in the book
so you find your transformation because
the subtitle of the book like you just
read it as
the bridge from your dreams to your
destiny and i believe and i'd love to
hear your response because you've
interviewed and done the 10 points of
your own and everybody else
don't you think everybody has a great
destiny a hundred percent
and the point is that that's why by the
way i'm getting goosebumps which for me
is corroboration and truth
one of the seven things discernments dr
canfield and i came up with jack
that the point is if you have a destiny
and you're alive you've still got a
destiny
and what what happens is so many people
are being sequestered and they're having
life force
energy sequ squished out of them
would you agree with that yeah a
thousand percent yeah so what happens is
that we're saying hey look buddy up with
somebody get a copy asked
and then go through every question
because socrates said to you and i and
everyone
you know the unexamined life is not
worth living so why not examine it why
not
figure out you know ask yourself who am
i and what am i supposed to do and what
is my right livelihood like my right
livelihood
is you know being a i'm right now
world's best-selling author i haven't
sold a half billion books but i want to
sell a billion which
by the way you know my critics that and
you know the critics of all the people
you've interviewed and done
everybody says you can't do stuff and
then what do we do we go out and do it
right
absolutely i love it yeah by the way i
you know it just it's so exciting like
i'll just do the quick aside right now
as everyone said well you don't
understand i can't work because of blah
blah and i said look
one of my heroes who i've never met is
elon musk who you've done stuff with and
musk
what did he do he got shut down so he
calls up 3m and said hey you can't make
these uh
ventilators fast enough i'll make them i
got 3d printing i got metal i got
engineered
but he kept making cars so he made 90
000 cars became the number one
car guy in the world during the time
technically he's supposed to be shut
down
in other words those of us that learn
the principles that you so eloquently
teach
distill and share if the people will get
him
and get them viscerally like your word
is belief my word is destiny
but the point is that once you've got
that you you become a
transcendent human being right if you
ask god your soul
transcends and you get to pull off stuff
that nobody else can pull
off i agree i mean so earlier this year
i was in
puerto rico brendan burchard invited me
to his event
with all of his friends to do a little
mastermind and
i spent the week before with him and and
just before we started the mastermind he
said evan
you've given so much to my audience and
on stages that
here i need to make sure that you ask
for something because i don't want you
to spend these four days with all these
leaders
and you're just giving and you don't
come away with something for you as well
um and that really kind of i was i was
kind of nerve-wracking because people
who sold companies for billions of
dollars and
and you know people who i look up to and
respect and to to
ask was very scary um and sometimes i
got most of the time i got a yes
but sometimes i gotta know too sometimes
they said
no i can't help you with that and um and
it wasn't that bad
you know like you're you're no worse off
are you
no i mean did it hurt your heart or soul
when they said no
um i thought it would be a lot worse
you know like i had this i guess mental
image in my head that
oh my god i'm gonna ask you something
they're gonna think i'm whatever a scam
artist they're just trying to just kind
of take take take
um arrogant or whatever right yeah and
it wasn't that bad it's like no i can't
help you with that it's like okay
and it didn't impact their conversations
it didn't impact the rest of the
the sessions together um and so i was
super grateful that brendan took me
aside before we started to say hey make
sure that you
ask and and as soon as i saw your book
he's like oh my gosh this
is this is it now you know for the world
that you have to ask the way wouldn't it
be nice if everybody could ask and then
move forward and yes we're all going to
have some rejection
and peter goober the guy who owns the
warriors and the dodgers and
50 academy awards is a dear friend of
ours and he said mark
i'm not dyslexic but he said you're so
dyslexic you think when people tell you
no it means on
and the point is you know when jack and
i wrote chicken soup 144 publishers
turned us down which is unbelievable
at some levels even to me but jackson
though i don't know if we're gonna do it
in our spouses at the time
said look you guys got things slipped
stacked up what are you guys doing don't
you get it nobody wants i said
no the audience wants it everyone says
do you have those stories in the book so
we put them in a book and
obviously the rest of history i mean and
luckily i've written 309 books
and and all of what you were saying a
minute ago everyone's got to learn to
ask
and and we've got to overcome all the
the withholds in our own
beingness to go ask
what are some of the questions that you
so you know list of questions in the
book what do you think is are some of
the most important questions to start
practicing first
okay so let's let's go backwards just
one step and say hey look there's seven
withholds
right and and self-worth is it and and
number two is fear and number three is
excuseology and
and number four is uh disconnection
which unfortunately so many
millennials i and we've got five kids
and six grandkids so we've got a lot of
millennials
right now so i i know it they're
spending so much screen time and missing
out on the world but the bigger
questions you gotta ask is
the question all three questions who
you know ask yourself ask other ask god
but at that level of ask god when jack
and i wanted the best title
in our respective houses he lived in
santa barbara california i live now in
scottsdale but at the time i lived in
newport beach
we did 400 times mega best selling title
make the best selling title mega best
selling time like the best thing before
we went to sleep
jack calls me up at 2 58 in the morning
this before cell phones
this is a 1989 the whole house gets you
know we thought something was wrong
and uh jack said chicken soup i said
brother soul i said we got it and we
both got goosebumps so we knew we had
so the point is and answer your question
the biggest question you ask is god
what's your destiny for me and by the
way if god is not the word you can use
there's 367 words for god right infinite
intelligence
immutable beauty or whatever you want to
use right total wisdom
but the point is if you do it a couple
hundred times my wife as you know is a
a lot of things but a clinical
hypnotherapist you go into the deeper
resources of the mind
and the mind always has to answer now it
may not answer immediately it may not
answer like you expect but it will
answer so if you say
what is my destiny and you really go to
the depth of your heart and soul
everyone has one like let me ask you
what do you think your
total destiny is i want to solve the
world's biggest problem
which i believe to be people don't
believe in themselves enough
i know and that's what you said this
morning on your 10 things that your
i guess your wife and family gave you as
a christmas envelope which i thought was
very
that if you're going to do something
personal that is nice
to do something so loving and so
personal and and i would agree with you
and i would agree that the four billion
people that are in poverty without
water without food without energy and
without education which is one of my
beliefs is that we've got to change that
and and you and i are at the vanguard of
that
right you're either leading edge cutting
edge dull edge or trailing edge and i'm
saying those about the few of us the two
of us here that are leading edge can get
to everybody for the first time
on the technology called smartphone i
won't use anybody's name how's that
yeah i love it and we're here doing it
here on an instagram live going through
a youtube video too
yeah but but the point is somebody in
swahili can listen because they can do
today with universal translators you
know they can take every word we do and
it's
98 accurate that's close enough we're
not going to say anything
so esoteric they can't get it right and
and so i'm saying you and i can get to
the poor support change their mindset
change their belief set
change their destiny set i think i've
covered the three things that you and i
just talked about if i missed any you
add to it
no i i love it uh and your heroes
are way more accessible than they ever
used to be
by the way 100 i mean just
in the old days you and i as famous as
we quasi are in our respective dominions
probably couldn't get to edison right
what i said in 1898
during the depression the first
sequestration in america
four things came out of it we got the
wright brothers got everybody to fly
right now it's a multi-trillion dollar
industry we've got a guy
create electricity named edison we got a
guy create the automobile name henry
ford
and and we create the telephone so out
of these
shutdowns right where you have silent
time you can really think and find out
who you are
and like i see people from new zealand
and everywhere listening to us right now
god bless
the the point is that couldn't happen
back then so nobody could get to anybody
but now when you and i
like i'll just do me and then i'll bet
you'll agree we've done
in i've always loved podcasts and and
people listen to seven and a half hours
a week right now but
the fact of the matter is that in one
day we are two in america one in canada
one in israel
and and 10 million people in vietnam and
their reaction because everyone's buying
on amazon
the book sales have gone through the
roof and if you told me
in the old days i would have said let me
go to the 20 best bookstores in america
but they're all bankrupt right now
and by the way i'm not laughing at that
i'm laughing at the inanity of a tragic
terrible situation that we shouldn't be
in
a hundred percent and you know book
sales were actually on the decline and
then it started going up again
because a lot of people were doing
youtube deals
and selling books through youtube and
people are
going out of their way that i'm thankful
to say to read some of my books and then
once they start reading me
you know just like i expect you follow
authors like i've watched i think 90
percent of your shows i mean i'm sure i
missed some but
you know i've watched a lot of them
because i if if i if i am successful
then i want to stay successful
and your input determines your
throughput and your output
then you need to be listening to you
know the 10 points you're making
here there and everywhere and everyone's
got somebody that can
be their mentor even surrogately meaning
electronically if they can't get to them
physiologically
yeah i call them aspirational mentors
but surrogate mentors can work too
by the way aspirational works for me i'm
not going to argue that
the point is you are where you are
because of a lot of mentors and what you
just said brendan's one of my students
in the old days i
i was at jacob javid center we had like
60 000 people at one time
and you know because we were the book of
the year and all that and then we had a
breakout session i let him
the first talk he did on his golden
ticket was with us so i
i think the world of that kid a young
man he's not a kid anymore
and in terms of looking up to your
leaders like brendan as an example may
not be taking on
you know an intern so that you can go
hang out with him all day long
but you can watch his videos and you can
watch his instagrams you can see him on
youtube and you can read his books and
you can learn from him you could be
around
your heroes every single day if you
wanted to you just
gotta go online to find them yeah and
they're all there and even some of the
old-timers like in graduate school i was
with bucky fuller dr buckminster
for seven years as a research assistant
einstein's best student arguably
and and you know today all of his hours
of tape that we made 50 years ago
some of my peers have put it online so
there even some of the old-timers you're
getting to and then
the other thing is we were interviewed
by um
adam carolla and he says he's doing
documentaries now and the documentaries
are brilliant on stuff that you would
never get to have a documentary on
before
because there wasn't the bandwidth but
now because of the internet and i'd
even argue against this if i'm wrong but
um we have unlimited bandwidth
so it's so good you're not gonna argue
against it so what happens is you've got
to really ask yourself what is it you
want when i went bankrupt in 1974
you know and i was sleeping out in front
of another guy's room in a sleeping bag
for six months in hicksville long island
new york
it finally dawned on me what i wanted to
do i want to talk to people that care
about things that matter that would make
a life changing difference
so i go to my three roommates in
hicksville long island new york and i
said
boy i know there's a big question you
guys but i want to ask you guys is there
anyone young that's talking that's not a
celebrity
not a doctor not a lawyer not a famous
person guy said yeah there's a kid a few
years older than you out here in hawaii
and here's my ticket i'm a real estate
guy go out there while i rush my
the bankruptcy courts are taking
everything but a little beat up old
volkswagen
i go out to hop on listen to this guy
mesmerize the audience chip collins for
three hours
i go up to him at the end i say i'm mark
their trans i like to buy you lunch
if you'll teach me how to do the
business he said kid if you'll stay out
of real estate because i own the five
boroughs here in new york
i'll teach you but a chance 1 000 you're
gonna make it you ain't gonna make it i
just want to tell you
so i don't think you should waste your
time so let me make that decision
he taught me what to do i did a tony
robbins i were talking at one big
meeting we did together
i said only you and i did a thousand
meetings a year for the first three
years if i wasn't talking i was selling
little speeches
to little insurance agencies which were
easy because they
desperately needed training and it was
great battleground for me and
then they said yeah that story in a book
and i said uh
no but i'm gonna do it so this book
behind me right behind the top of my
head that uh
yellow that says stand up speak out and
win yeah
i self-printed it and we sold 20 000
copies i mean the first year
i i tripled my income i went to remember
this 1974 so
back then 20 000 10 each 20 000 copies
i thought i died and gone to heaven and
i said look everybody this isn't a new
york times bestseller
this isn't an international bestseller
it's not a national bet so
but it's my best seller and i want
autographs to you you're watching your
kids and your dog if you have one
i love it every twenty thousand people
have bought them
and what does that mean well you gotta
ask yourself other than god well i asked
myself what i want to do and it was my
right level and then
i want to be world best-selling author
and that was my next right livelihood
but each of us have to have this
evolving sense of destiny and you got to
figure out what you want and it's got to
be put in writing
and right now is a perfect time for us
to do the self-interrogation the self
inquiry to say hey what is it i can do
it how is it i can do it how far can i
go
because there's it's the wrong time to
live below your privilege because the
world needs us to come out of our
cocoons
and and manifest our highest best
noblest and most exciting
i love it now the book is called ask
it's the new one that's just that we've
been
talking about a whole bunch of amazing
things but talking about the book again
uh can you walk me through the cover
because when i see the cover
i think like magical is the word that
comes to mind i don't know what
what you were thinking when you're kind
of designing that tell me about the
cover and how you came up with it
well by the way first of all thank you
for that request but the cover is
is mystical and it's also got because
remember one of my degrees is synergetic
energetic geometry but
it it has um you know the whole
geometry of the universe internet but it
looks sort of like a ferris wheel to
somebody who doesn't know any better
or like an ozai if you're down in mexico
and then
ask is such a profound question we
needed it to bounce off the shelves
and you know i teach how to i wrote a
book called
you have a book in you because i want
everyone to write their book and
discover who they are
but this jumps off the bookshelf at 200
feet and most people's covers
are so dull and so boring and so non-uh
visible so they don't jump off stage
because what we say is look
in the book business you want this space
out in the window if you can get it you
want it at the cash register
you want it at the end aisle i mean i've
learned all the tricks of
the book business when the book business
worked like the book business but now
the book business is called an amazon
business because amazon
literally became the earth's largest
bookstore and i'm the only guy that ever
melted down jeff bezos which i'm glad to
tell you that story if you want but the
point is
um because he said nobody can melt me
and sell more than i can deliver well
that's not
true jeff anyhow so we can pull that off
can't we
so the point is we my wife came up with
the cover idea and then we had it
finalized and it just it is forgive me
for bragging but it's miraculous
at the very bottom is a bridge which we
call a bridge of destiny
which goes with the story that she wrote
we had the world's longest prologue
if you studied my stuff i say if you're
going to do business or write books you
got to
number one be unique number two it's
whatever it is got to be
transformational number three it's got
to be inevitable that when they get it
they love
it they adore it and they'll share it
with all their friends and
help you go forward with it so um
thank you for adoring our cover we're i
got to tell you of all the covers i've
ever had that is the best cover
it pops instantly i mean as soon as when
your team reached out and uh
and sent the graphic oh my gosh i love
this book
and magical was just the word that came
to mind now like i couldn't put my
i couldn't put my my finger on it but i
love it i mean studying design and i do
a lot with thumbnails for youtube videos
because it's the same game you need
people to click
on the video you gotta you gotta win the
click and a thumbnail of a video is the
same as the cover for the book you could
have the greatest book in the world but
if
the cover is going to be really hard to
get people to take it off the shelves or
pick it off amazon and want to dive
further so
um yeah i really i really love that idea
um
perfect go ahead you can do the next
question i just want to compliment you
on that because
two things number one you gotta have a
killer title that the audience
emotively gets to because everyone knows
they are either really good at asking
and they want to know better how to get
better
or they really suck at asking and then
they want to learn how to ask i've never
said that before
but i think that's accurate those are
the only two models that i can see in my
head do you see anything different
no let's dive into that a little bit so
if somebody feels like they suck at
asking
they stuck with asking they've always
tucked it asking the parents sucked it
asking
you know kind of the mindset of uh i'm
never going to get good at this
uh but they know they want more and they
know they need help and they know they
can't do it
all on their own but that this is like
the single biggest thing that is
blocking them from getting where they
need to be is
the ability to ask so i suck at asking
mark what do i do
look if you and our neighbors you're
geographically up by my buddy
proctor up there in toronto and he's one
of my best friends of course but is it i
would say
let's simulate this and let's go through
every question but
we have all the people we tested because
i test we believe
uh testing feedback as a breakfast
champions everybody we tested on that
goes through this
becomes a master asker that's number one
number two is that once you've got the
book
we're saying go to askthebookclub.com
we're having a free
once a month we're meeting with
everybody for free we figured we want
everyone to become masterful at asking
and if they got any questions
asking that they can't answer we'll help
reorient them
or get them to the depth of their asking
ability individually
collectively and then for god or spirit
how's that
and with that what's videos
askthebookclub.com
yeah askthebookclub.com is free to
everybody and we want everyone to do it
and then
back to the second thing you said about
the cover you've got to have a great
cover but you
we need to dress well we need to address
our websites well and our clicks well
and our social media well and so i i am
thankful and then
unless you tell me something different
we've never seen anyone integrate
both purple which is god's highest color
with pink and and blazing it with
sunshine coming out
have you ever seen a cover like this
before no uh
all right remember i said you got to be
unique it's got to be transformational
and you go
i'll look at that oh wow that's a guy
who sold more books than anybody else
and his wife
his wife must be smarter than he is
which is really true you've got to
interview her because she's wiser
smarter
and way more beautiful and i'm thankful
i uh
did well because by the way can i do
that real quick
what when i when i was divorced and and
desperate for the right woman i wrote
2006 i asked myself what would be
a perfect ideal mate a twin a a soul
mate
and i wrote 267 things i'd like to have
in my ideal
person and uh the woman i met and
married is
is 267.267 we have the same values b
monogamous
have our own business you know love to
travel want to do the kind of thinking
that we're doing here which is
you know evolving because you're either
evolving or
involving and involving doesn't mean
devolving
i should have said right those are the
two
the life world is paul uh has polar
opposites black and white and
right and the point is that you and i
either are growing or
contracting and you and i are in the
business that we want to help everyone
grow because
if every if somebody grows everyone's
better off would you agree with that
absolutely yeah i mean what we said is
that somebody makes a million employees
directly and indirectly 10 people and
somebody makes a billion
employs 10 000 people so we need more
billionaires not less and we've never
had more
i love it and the secret is to ask yeah
and the point is every one of us can ask
so can i do a great ask story that we
have in the book
okay so you may know jim stovlon if you
haven't had him on your show you've got
to have him but
jim is going to be our superstar athlete
he's trained he's fast at 19 years old
he gets
recruited by the nfl the national
football league in america
they go in and a doctor comes back with
a coach shaking his head and said kid
i'm sorry but you're going to be totally
permanently blind in six months
nothing we can do about it well now he's
self-incarcerated in a little nine by 12
room
and he's got a telephone a television
and a radio
and his parents say look quit
complaining just do do yourself a favor
go to the blind meeting well he goes
there and they're all complaining it's
an echo chamber
a negativity that isn't going to help
but he sits next to this woman named
kathy
and he said in the old days i used to
love to watch tv and somebody throw a
right hook and now i can't see it i wish
somebody would do something
she gently nudges him and here's the
question of the day out of our book
hey wait a second we're somebody we can
do something now you know i define an
entrepreneur as somebody who fixes a
problem
scales it and makes a vast profit right
and that's what he did he created with
kathy
something you and i wouldn't know about
because we're cited but narrative
television
14 million people pay 10 dollars a month
for the biggest third biggest streaming
service in the world
and then he wrote a book and and this is
when i first met him
and charlie tremendous jones said look i
know you're selling 50 million books a
year you got no time to do this
but i need you to read this book and
you're my friend so i'm i
beg you to do it i read it i said wow
this is the best book i've read
it's called the ultimate gift i wrote
the forward and the afterward
and i said this movie book's got to be a
movie it's so clear and if you haven't
read the ultimate gift by jim stovall i
want everyone to read it
and you say well you're selling other
people's books corns i sell anything
that's really good and helpful
and anyhow so we interviewed stovall for
our book ask
and he's nothing but pure wisdom the guy
is just pure
wisdom and he says i now write he said
first of all if i live a hundred years
there'll never be idea i don't
thanking my prayers you for changing my
mind and mindset mark
but he said i now write books that i
can't read
and i make movies he made a hundred
million dollars on the movie and it's a
great movie you got to see it you can
see on netflix called the ultimate gift
and you'll know all the stars but he
said i now make movies that i can't
watch
and he said except the covet happened
i'm supposed to be one of the
stars in one of the movies because i
said oh i got one of my crazy goals
jim i've never asked you for anything
other than interviews can can i be in
your movies
no no i wanted you to be in it you
crystal and so
is that amazing or is that amazing i
love it i love it
it's great because this starts yeah
because we're here to have joy
and like i'm 72 years young never call
yourself old because that disparages the
soul
and i'm going to live be 127 options for
renewal and if you have a high quality
of life why would you want high quality
for renewal i love it oh man what what a
great conversation i i know uh
we're coming up on the time uh the book
is called ask
uh go buy it on amazon we'll link it up
for youtube we'll put it in the
description below if you guys can once
get there and if you want to join mark's
uh ongoing program askthebookclub.com
it's free monthly sessions with him mark
appreciate the time and
best of luck on the book and and thanks
for sharing your time with us today
thank you for doing all the great good
you're doing you're doing superb work
thank you sir
i love it appreciate it thank you thank
you bye-bye
if you want to see the one-on-one i did
with seth godin check it out right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there skill this is really good news
is learnable when i started in the book
business i had bad taste
and editors didn't like what i thought
they would like